how are you doing today good good it's
always awkward when you start the
interview off you're like and how am I
gonna what am I gonna say so the last
time we spoke was at Sundance for Judy
and punch it was when are people gonna
be able to see judy in punch i believe
it's coming out in Australia in November
that's not much help to your viewers but
um
yeah I assume sometime after that in the
US I don't think they've locked in a
date yet I saw that it's coming up for
people don't realize we should just plug
it real quick who do you play in Judy
and punch I played punch who's married
to Judy who this is based sort of
loosely on Iran an old puppet show
that's been particularly popular in in
the UK and Europe and other Commonwealth
countries like Australia in Canada for
hundreds of years and it's a it's it's
essentially taking that that puppet show
and turning it into a live-action couple
of the of the puppets
I believe it's coming out I'll plug the
UK for you in November as well right yes
so but like I really enjoyed your work
in it and I really hope that people get
to see it soon I hope so it's an amazing
film and Mia Wasikowska is is in it
mirror folks is it's a first feature
writing directing and she's such an
incredible talent so yeah I hope people
get to get to check it out
jumping into why you are here um listen
there's a lot I want to talk about the
first is how amazing your work is and we
can see it on the screen in mine hundred
season two that work is cuz there's a
genius makeup artist from Japan because
I wouldn't have I wouldn't have looked
so much like Charles Manson with that
without him but sorry goes you know
believe me when I say if you have not
seen or if you're if you're not watching
mind hunter on Netflix it's one of the
best shows on any channel and season two
is incredible and I mean that's all I
have it's just an amazing show I want to
jump backwards so a lot of people know
or have learned that you basically
played Manson in two projects and so
let's jump backwards and talk about what
happened first was it mind hunter was it
Quentin how did it all start yeah it
went on to happen considerably
earlier than once upon a time in
Hollywood mine hunter probably happened
around the beginning of last year which
was really cool for me because it was
about a six-month lead-up time to really
do a deep dive into Charles Manson I
mean I knew who he was I knew I'd read
helter skelter I'd watch documentaries
but I went seriously immerse myself into
watching pretty much I think everything
you can find online and read a few books
listen to some podcasts I'd listen to
his music did a whole bunch of stuff and
then once upon a time in Hollywood
really just came about by coincidence
are only a couple of weeks before I was
about to shoot mine hunter and it only
had ended up shooting a couple of weeks
after I shot mind hunter so despite them
coming about completely separately and
and yeah I ended up shooting them really
close to each other which was kind of
bizarre but also kind of cool I guess so
I have to ask did you you book mind
Hunter you're going to meet with the
people for Quentin's project are you
telling them hey I'm also doing mind
Hunter or is it sort of like mentioned
is more of the latter I mean I was
actually I was in Australia when when
once upon a time in Hollywood came up
came up the audition for that and it was
just gonna be a self tape that I did and
when I came in I was kind of like man
this is like the best and worst day ever
for an actor because I just got an
audition for a Quentin Tarantino movie
and there is no way he's ever gonna cast
me in this role because I'm already
playing this role and I didn't mention
it then but but then the second we found
out that I got the role then you know he
was told immediately because I assumed
that that that would be you know enough
of a turn-off to find someone else but
thankfully he was like no that that's
cool
he'd mind okay so we're now I want to
jump into so you book mind Hunter I mean
you're gonna do mind hunter before
Quentin mmm-hmm
okay so what was it like I'm gonna do
minor spoilers here in terms of this is
very very minor but it's a you play it's
a key scene
in season two the first thing is did you
film more than one scene or was it just
always gonna be that one thing no it was
always just gonna be that one scene okay
so the next thing is how long did you
guys work behind the scenes to craft
that look - for the episode well there
was an initial kind of I guess a fitting
or or or a plaster cast and all that
kind of stuff none of my head and and
wrapped in plastic on all kinds of
different stuff that kazoo does to get a
perfect cast of your own head that
happened I think maybe in January last
year and we didn't shoot till August
before we shot there were two more times
that we that I met with him
one was for like a temporary fitting
where I looked almost like that but not
not quiet
and then in the week before shooting we
did a final test of the look which was
kind of really just honing it and
getting it getting it to look like that
was there on set any sort of let's keep
you away from the actors so that you're
seeing you for the first time when
you're walking in well it I don't know
if that was intentional but that we did
do something like that so on the day
that that I had that final makeup test I
actually had met the actors because we
did a little rehearsal with Andrew
Dominik the episodes director and David
Fincher so we had already met them but
then they were already on set shooting a
scene with that Kemper and Cameron
Britten obviously brilliant actor and so
I walked on and and it was kind of this
moment where Madison met Kemper because
I walked understand and he was there I
was like hey and I hadn't met him before
and you looked like that I looked like
that yeah yeah
and and there's a photo of that summer
actually the onset photographer took a
picture of that I I haven't seen it but
I'd like to track that down and then I
walked into to see Jonathan and halt and
yet they were point I mean everybody was
was blown away by how it looked you know
the whole crew were just like what
because it looked you know yeah Kazu is
a master of what he does and I it looked
like Charles Manson was walking
around the place it was people would
just freaked out yeah I was so impressed
when you walk out on screen I'm like oh
my god like it is a dead ringer you know
and you know you can't you know a couple
of active friends have said oh you know
did you like that or was that kind of
was that did that put you off having to
be covered up with it like put me off it
was like brilliant it for me it's like I
look in the mirror and go okay well
thank you Kazu for doing half of my job
for me you know it I feel like it
already takes you to where you need to
be immediately well I believe that it
takes you to where you physically and
look but the thing that I also just
loved was the dialog and what he's
spewing out and trying to you know
because he people have these
preconceived notions of who he was and
you obviously did a deep dive but what
the thing about mind hunter that what it
portrays is that there's many ways of
reading what what Manson was doing and
what he was really about and the episode
sort of or the episodes talk about that
so what did you walk away with in terms
of your understanding of him maybe or do
you have a new understanding of him I
was very relieved to hear recently that
Matt Smith who plays Charles Manson in a
movie called Charlie says I had despite
doing all the research he did had come
away still not really knowing what what
made Manson tick because I feel exactly
the same way I mean I couldn't have read
and watched more about the guy and I
still don't really know who he was in
his inner moments in his inner thoughts
what he truly believed about anything
because you got a different Manson on
any given day that you happen to be
speaking to him depending on the mood he
was in depending on the attitude the
interviewer came to with him sometimes
he behaves there's an interview online
with him with Ron range Ron Reagan jr.
where he speaks to Manson like he's
interviewing a like a completely normal
person like he might as well be speaking
to a president or something he just
talks to him normally and Manson doesn't
really do any crazy stuff he sort of
tries briefly at one point and it feels
completely wrong for the
interview and then he goes back to just
talking calmly and normally then other
interviews you see he's being kind of
riled up and and and kind of poked and
called crazy and he does the crazy
Manson that we all kind of know so it's
it's so hard to pin him down I think
sometimes and sometimes he would say
things and you're like wow you you have
really just explained something about
the world I never thought about and
that's kind of genius and other times he
would say something else in his a
similar way but it just seems like the
rantings of a madman and I don't know I
think he just opened his mouth he never
really stopped to think and I think he
often just opened his mouth and spoke
stuff and sometimes but whatever he was
saying it sounded kind of mesmerizing
but whether it made any sense or not
dependent on that particular moment how
long did it take to film that sequence
in mind Hunter oh yeah three days yeah
so it was it was it was a you know there
were big days because I don't you know
it was nearly five hours in makeup each
morning and then twelve hours filming
after that just doing that one scene yes
so they do do they do a lot of a lot of
coverage on that show and a lot of takes
and yeah it's definitely definitely the
hardest job I've ever done physically
for sure it's interesting because a lot
of people associate Fincher with the
person who does a lot of takes so I'll
actually I know Andrew directed it but
is Fincher on mind enter when he's not
directing is he around all the time in
my experience on those three days he was
there quite a bit I would say maybe
fifty to sixty percent of the time he
was around and he was just awesome you
know it was just so cool to just have
breaks and going to sit down and be
chatting to this guy who was just so
lovely and you know happy to talk about
his old movies and yeah he's just so
cool it was a real real joy for me to
get to meet him yeah anytime I've been
lucky enough to talk to him and it's the
same thing with James Cameron they're
just the smartest people in the room
yeah you know they're he's operating on
another level which explains his work
yeah I mean you know I think people
forget how many amazing films he's
directed he even if you know films go
back and look at his IMDB you just be
like oh that's right
that oh my god it's nuts how many
masterpieces the guys made and yeah it
was just a real honor for me to be a
part of that
hell no what I'm curious about is Holt
told me that Carl Franklin is more of
the one who might improvise a little bit
on set
but I'm curious did you get the script
that you have for the sequence how early
did you have the dialogue and how did it
if at all shift through the development
and you know being on set I mean when I
auditioned there was a scene but I would
say by the time we actually shot there
was maybe 25% of that scene left but
that wasn't anything to do with the
rehearsal process or anything that was
just the behind the scenes the writers
working on it I think Andrew Dominik had
quite a bit of input on the the writing
of the scene as well as it appears on
screen so I think that the final version
that I got was probably you know maybe
ten days before we shot something like
that do they do a table read of the
episode each episode or do they not do
table reads not well actually we did do
what we did do a Skype read of the
episode well wasn't Skype it was some
other kind of fancy industry Skype where
they were like literally 20 faces that
you're looking at we did do that a few
months before shooting when when you're
doing something like that how much is it
just you saying the dialogue in like
just a normal voice and how much are you
sort of putting a spin on it in a table
read yeah that's a good question I mean
normally you would try and do the table
read roughly how you gonna do it but
normally it's not that much of a
departure from yourself so this was a
bit of a weird one because I was on the
Skype thing on camera but just with my
own normal face but kind of going well
I've got to do the Manson version cuz
that's what I auditioned with and that's
who he is and if I just don't do it
maybe I'll lose the gig so I was kind of
doing it but I did feel a bit silly
because I was like
it's gonna be so much better I can could
I got the mask on you know and I mean
completely have they mentioned to you
that possibly because I've heard halter
said and some of the people have said
that the idea is from 900 to be a five
five seasons right that's the that's if
it you know that's the rumor
have they said anything to you when you
were there about you know Manton could
come back or seven no no I had they
certainly haven't said anything like
that to me I want to jump in now into
Quinn's project you rap on mind hunter
that had to have been a crazy experience
and then you're singing to me it's weeks
later you're playing him again
on the set of a Quentin Tarantino movie
yeah yeah it was it was I mean as I say
it was bizarre but it was also cool
because in terms of things like the way
he moves in his demeanor and I mean it's
the same character so the a big chunk of
any of the work that an actor might do
in preparation for a rose already done
it had been done for months but there
were some differences as well obviously
there's a big tonal difference between a
Tarantino movie and an mind hunter and
also Manson as I didn't really know this
before but just looking into it he he
was kind of different
in 1969 from 1980 I mean I think 11
years ago I was probably kind of the
same guy but he had a noticeable change
in the way he spoke his voice is a lot
lighter in in in the stuff that I was
able to find earlier on it kind of got
very gruff very quickly and he kind of
became very bitter in jail you know it's
it's most of his jail interviews he's
really he's pretty pissed off that he's
there and he wants everyone to know
about it
in 1969 he's living in a commune with
you know all these girls and drugs and
he's he's kind of the king of his world
and he's trying to make it as a
recording artist and life's pretty good
so he's kind of got this kind of sort of
a joyful playful quality to him so it
was nice being able to find those those
differences rather than just just going
into both in exactly the same way I
heard that Quentin's first cut on once
upon a time was like four hours
I think I think that he said it was four
hours 20 or something yes
something along those lines and I've
heard that in the movie that is released
that people see you have I believe it's
one scene or is it - it's essentially
wait I guess you'd call it - but yeah so
um but I heard that there were a number
of other sequences that you filmed is
that true or not true oh look a tiny bit
no so I wouldn't I wouldn't say a number
of other sequences there was a little
bit more I think there's given that
there was you know it's a it was a four
hour 20 minute movie and it's now a 2
hour 45 minute movie there's obviously a
lot you know that was shot that's not in
it so I think probably everybody lost a
bit of stuff over that period but yeah
there's there's some other a little bit
more amount of stuff which you know
maybe one day we'll see the light of day
and and I hope so because I can't give
away what it was but it was it was
Quentin's writing at his best it's a
particular one particular scenes
particularly brilliantly written that I
heard there's one this is what I heard
and maybe you can confirm this I heard
that this the a really really great
scene of yours as Manson is not in the
theatrical cut and hopefully we will see
it down the road on Netflix or wherever
they're gonna release an extended cut
true well yeah I mean there was
definitely another scene that I thought
was one of the best things I've ever
read in my life you know just on the
page and yeah I hope I hope that I hope
you're right I genuinely don't know if
it'll ever but but but you know I think
he's shown a an interest in in going
back to his older movies and making
longer versions and given that this one
was so long to start with I think it
would be a pretty great candidate for
that listen I I think the movies amazing
and it's one of my favorites of that in
his of all the movies he's made I think
he he transports you to another time in
place and you feel like you're there
yeah Andy yeah it's unbelievable what he
did with this film you're absolutely
right I mean it I think you just know
it's not just a period movie and
although it's Saturday 1969 he takes you
there and I think that attention to
detail like changing Hollywood Boulevard
for real rather than doing CG all that
stuff it makes such a difference you can
feel you can feel the era when you're
watching it and you kind of yeah you get
a nostalgia for a time I mean I wasn't
even born in 1969 but I kind of you kind
of want to be there you know it he's
really he's a master at that yeah and
also it captures this time where the
like the the age before innocence was
lost in Hollywood yes you know he just
he it's just so effing good and so I
want to see every minute that here I
moved so if he's like there's a 4-hour
cut we're gonna show it one week at the
Vista I'd be like here's my money let me
see it I think a lot of people would
feel that way actually I think he's one
of those one of those directors where
you know you just want to see everything
they've shot because completely so good
and you don't want it to be any anything
hiding anyway you're gonna see it all
because I'll tell you this I interviewed
James Marsden before the movie came out
a number of months back for a project
and you know he did work on once upon a
time in Hollywood told me all about
working on it blah blah blah like you
know what it was like working with
Quentin shared some great stories he's
not in the movie like he's one of the
people that has been removed and there's
like five or six people like that yeah
that were just cut out and I am like my
god that is him lost I mean who doesn't
see Tim Roth you know yeah no exactly so
I for one definitely want to see that
that version so completely if it happens
I want to move on to something else
which is something I'm so excited about
Barry Jenkins Underground Railroad
mm-hmm um have you wrapped on that or
he's still filming no I see I just
started so it that they've only just
started filming that and I started on
about a week ago and it's okay
yeah it's it's all very new it's um it's
awesome the scripts are incredible and
and the role is really cool I play a not
horrible person this time so that's a I
was actually one area nice little I was
wondering
playing an a-hole or you're gonna I'm
really trying to avoid the aisles for a
while now I think a good couple of years
off the aisles I've kind of reached peak
a hole got it yes well for people that
don't realize he's directing as far as I
know all eleven episodes yeah which is
unbelievable because a I mean he's kind
of talented he did suggest a bit but
it's also it's based on a critically
acclaimed book um what so what are you
allowed to say about the show I don't
want to get you in trouble well I I can
say that I play a character called
Martin Wells who's in the book who and
his character is along with his wife is
they play a couple that there are a
couple in the show who are helping the
main character of Cora escape from
slavery in the south and try and help
her get towards the North to freedom and
safety and so one particular episode
takes place at mostly at Martin and his
wife's house and and as they're kind of
trying not to get caught with someone
hiding in their attic and it's it's
pretty tense it's like it's brilliantly
done because there's a whole bunch of
stuff you know just the relationship
between all of them but you've also got
that added tension you know of kind of
and Frank kind of stuff of you know
someone's what's that noise up there you
know people coming over for dinner and
hearing creaking in the floorboards and
all that kind of stuff so it's it's it's
really really cool the writing is great
the roll is great it's great playing
someone who's helping somebody rather
than killing them and ya know it's it's
I'm pretty pretty stoked to be on it art
is your character on all the whole
series or no no he pays in a couple of
episodes
got it okay so it's one of these things
where you can enjoy the project and
you're not and you can do other things
at the same time yeah yeah my buddy from
Australia joel edgerton has one of the
the lead roles he's he's he's in it the
whole way through and I think he's
playing someone who's a little
unpleasant so I'm happy family right to
take the reins on that one where are you
guys filming in Georgia okay Atlanta
yeah
and uh Savannah yeah okay was that
that's a well I mean that's very apropos
for what it all is yeah yeah you know
did you get all the scripts that you're
working on or is it just one at a time
no just just the just the ones on one
yes I just thought just a couple I'm
doing got it but it's it's so well
written it's gonna be really good yeah
he's been working on it for since
moonlight I think right it's this is one
of these things where you mean he's been
and also listen it says a lot that
someone on that level who could pick a
project and get it greenlit is making
this exactly his then yeah I mean that
means it's you know a you must be very
passionate about it and be it must be
hella written to use you know bad
English yes yes no I get what you mean
you know it's really it's gonna be it's
gonna be pretty special I mean with the
writing and the cast they've got and and
and him directing it's gonna be gonna be
a pretty special show jumping onto
something else you also worked with Sir
Ben Kingsley recently yes yes that was
that was pretty awesome I mean an end
this is on a show called perpetual grace
limited which is on epics he plays my
dad in the show we sadly don't have any
scenes together in season 1 which is
kind of sucks when you know that you're
going to be playing the son of Ben
Kingsley and you don't have any scenes
with Ben Kingsley but I met him
obviously and he was incredibly lovely
and you know he's just one of the best
actors alive and I'm so such a fan of
you know so many of his roles over the
years sexy beasts probably being my
favorite so yeah it was I'm hoping that
you know we have a season two and father
and son get some stuff together because
that would be a career highlight for me
for sure um what for people that don't
realize what's the show about and when
can people see it well it's all it was
just screening on epic so I'm assuming
it's only the episode my bad stream is
right I should know these things that's
right that's okay that's gay there's a
lot of shows to keep up with at the
moment tell you something it's I don't
know how all I do is watch content right
and I
cannot keep up so I don't know how
anyone can do it possible its yeah it's
a show that stars Ben Kingsley and Jacki
Weaver and the incredible Jimmy Simpson
and Jimmy plays a character who is
trying to kind of escape his past life
and the regrets he has and he comes
across my character who essentially
pitches to him the idea of ripping off
my parents who are themselves crooks
they run a church called Our Lady of
Perpetual grace but they essentially
steal money from parishioners so it's
kind of a Robin Hood eesh hey let's
let's just take money from them because
they're bad guys anyway and that's kind
of how it that's how it starts off but
it's it's got Steve Conrad is the writer
director creator showrunner he's a
genius check him out on IMDB if you
don't know his name because he's been
around for forever and done so many
great projects there's a lot of
different story tangents to this show
and a lot of amazing characters and it's
yeah it's pretty cool it's got this Coen
Brothers II kind of tone and it was
awesome so I hope it I hope it goes
again I was I'm jumping into something
else one of the shows that I wish had
more had gotten more episodes was quarry
I really do I really thought that show
was so well done yeah and if people
haven't seen it before it ran for one
season totally worth watching you were
on it and do you was that one of those
shows that you're like oh yeah we
everybody involved in that show from all
you know the cast the crew we just loved
it it was so beautifully written it was
beautifully directed the other cast I
got to work with were all extraordinary
the photography was stunning the tone of
it and and the the kind of had this
amazing story and characters and
dialogue it was everything you kind of
wanted and it was it was just one of
those things where you know I think some
some people have suggested that you know
it was produced by HBO but screened on
Cinemax and maybe it was probably more
of an HBO style show and they maybe
should have screened it on HBO because
essentially not a lot of people saw it I
think but the people who saw it
really dug it and yeah I love that show
yeah I was one of those people um and
yeah I mean listen there's the HS sucks
but I get it it's the business yeah
do you know what I mean does it ever get
a day has it slowed down with people
calling you do we ha ha or is it still
every day you're waiting in line at
supermarket and there's always someone
who's gonna say it no it's not that
comic cuz I mean I don't know that
people are expecting to see you know
obviously you have to be a fan of
justified to know who do he is for a
start and they're a very you know there
are a lot of very big justified fans but
you know you had that those people have
to be standing in the same room that I
am and they're not expecting to see
Dewey Crowe you know at the Trader Joe's
in in Hollywood or whatever so you know
what happens but it's probably I mean
probably five times a year or something
it's not that common real yeah okay
maybe it's also like if you're look you
know if you have that you look like this
don't have yeah somatic tattoos on me
and I don't have the redneck haircut and
I'm not wearing the Gator tooth necklace
and the weird kind of shorts with long
johns
weirdly that's not my look of preference
I have to ask you though what was it
like wearing that on so you're filming
you're wearing your outfit how much or
do you actually have to be careful about
like not going in public especially like
California or I think you filmed in
California yeah yeah we did so well I
would never have gone out like that um I
remember that when we were shooting the
pilot we shot it in Pittsburgh and the
tattoos
did take a long time to put on and there
was one day where it got to the end of
the day and and I don't know even if a
lot of people realize this even who
watch the show but Dewey's neck tattoo
said Heil Hitler
it was in that really kind of whatever
that Nazi font of choices but you know
you gets kind of you know you can't
quite read it very clearly but that's
what it said
and
I had if I had the first seen up the
next day and you know there was a
discussion at one point of like well
let's just leave the tattoos on for
tonight because I'm gonna be first up
and that they haven't been destroyed and
I remember I went home in the tattoos
and then I kind of was about to go down
the street downtown in Pittsburgh to
kind of get some dinner and I looked in
the mirror and I saw this tattoo there I
was like oh I can't leave the house I
mean there's no way you know I really
should have thought ahead here so no do
we do we have to stay on on set how long
did it take you to do all that makeup
for Dewey yeah um it wasn't wasn't crazy
would probably be you know 3540 minutes
or something well that's not bad yeah um
yeah I was thinking it could be worse
right right maybe you hear these stories
though although TV production they don't
have time to know except for this which
was about four and a half hours here
well they had this thing called money in
time yes that's right that that's the
thing that I've heard about Fincher its
money in its money in time absolutely
you know that they have so much time on
that show and it's in it it's such a you
feel like wow you know if only
everything had this amount of time to
work on stuff because yeah nothing
really comes close to the time that they
spend yeah that's the thing with with
David but it's also that one of the
reasons why the show is so unbelievable
is it took them two years to make the
second season and the actors all told me
that it was because they David one of
the scripts to all be done to all be
perfect and that you know what I mean
yeah it's he has a way of doing things
and it translates to amazing things yeah
absolutely I mean when the attention to
detail is like it is I mean I think he's
probably you know a an absolute
perfectionist yeah because not
everything is perfect you know and you
watch that show and there's nothing out
of place there's not a piece of dialogue
or a shot or you know it's it's a pretty
cinematic piece of television I tell
everyone who I tell everyone you need to
watch the show I can't make it any
clearer um so obviously you're filming
Underground Railroad
but what's coming up after that or what
did you recently rap on well there's a
there's an Australian series that
screens on FX over here called mr. in
between totally and that's coming out on
September 12th and that's a really great
show if you if you haven't seen that
before check it out I'll try and track
down season one and then and then watch
it it's it's about a an Australian hit
man essentially the guy Scott Ryan who
plays him is also the writer of the
whole series he's a genius and yeah it's
it's very funny you get to see a hit
man's kind of family life and you know
being a single dad and also going out
and doing hits on people it's it's a
it's a very clever tone and it works so
brilliantly because of Scott's
performance and his writing so yeah I
think that's that's the next thing
coming out there's a film called the
nightingale in Australian film Jennifer
Kent who made the babadook it's her
second film that's out now in limited
release in America she was recently in
the studio here she was I think that's
probably it you've enough I'm just I was
trying to make sure we could you know
promote anything else but I really I
cannot wait for Underground Railroad and
I'm so happy for your success with all
of this stuff thank you so much I want
to thank you sincerely for coming in the
studio my pleasure
and until the next time I'll see you
then exactly
Thanks